congratulations we made it to the end of
2022. that means we get to look back in
all of our successes and woes but most
importantly we get to look back on all
the sweet games that we played which
means top 10 best of for us here at
Gamespot now I have to say this I always
have to say this it is never easy for us
to figure out this list it is always
very considerate we put a lot of time
and thought into it but without further
Ado here is gamespot's top 10 best games
of the year As Told by the people who
loved
foreign
[Applause]
I doubt you could even imagine
are you prepared to commit a cardinal
sin I command me now
and this point is no surprise that from
software are making a good game in the
year that they release a game like
wherever they put out is at this point
they're one of the most consistent
developers of all time the question was
how do they evolve and Elden ring is the
answer to that question it takes
everything that they're known for the
the soul of their games the challenge
the the kind of Discovery the
exploration the RPG open-endedness the
PVP the breadcrumb trail of
characterization and narrative and then
spreads it across a scale that they've
never attempted before maybe in small
small increments they've had areas that
are a little bit bigger than you're
probably used to but Elder ring is their
first real attempt at an open world game
and the fact that they pulled it off in
spectacular fashion has to be uploaded
it takes a lot of developers a long time
before they can really nail down how it
feels to be in an open world and they
managed it in one shot and it was to
focus on the key tenets of what makes
their game good and that is keep the
play a challenge and also give them a
sense of discovery that is entirely
their own that feels like they're
they're having a unique experience and
that's exactly what Ellen ring is about
you come out of a cave and the world is
your oyster going anywhere any direction
find something and figure out what to do
with it and you'll have a meaningful
experience with it whether it's looking
through a dungeon whether it's trying to
fight your way through a castle or
whether it's just helping out a random
NPC with a small Quest either you're
rewarded with some sort of
characterization moment or an item or
just a better understanding what makes
the world tick or gives you a better
kind of layout of where you are and
throughout that there's always surprises
that's the best thing about Alden ring
it's always throwing you curveballs
Elder ring is a game about forging your
own path through a world that will
reward you at every turn and give you a
sense of Discovery at every turn it is
an open world game unlike any other
because it gives you complete authorship
of how you go through it it has got
minimum requirements of defeating a
certain amount of elderly Lords before
you go and take on the final boss but
pretty much everything else is up to you
approach it how you want create the fun
you want and make the stories and the
memories that will last with you of your
own volition and that's why it is one of
the best games of 2022 for GameSpot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
at first glance is a cute zelda-like
Adventure game where you're a little fox
and you explore this world and you fight
monsters and if that's all it was it
would still be a good game but tunic is
so much more than that and what makes
tunic incredible is how it it leads you
to your own devices to discover its
Secrets probably the most clever thing
about tunic is the way it reveals
information you will collect Pages which
are gorgeously realized in this sort of
like SNES SNES era instruction manual
and they're these absolutely beautiful
uh like illustrations but importantly
most of it is written in the game's own
language that it made up so you don't
actually understand what it's saying but
you can Intuit what it's saying and and
so it's kind of like when you import
like a Japanese game as a kid and you
don't know what the heck this game is or
how this game works or even what the
story is but you're just pouring over
the manual and you're trying to figure
it out and and through that process of
just like combing through that manual
and playing the game you are are slowly
putting the pieces together of what the
story is or what you think the story is
and
I've never seen a game quite capture
that energy and that spirit in the game
itself and I think that is absolutely
just like
mind-blowing I think one of the most
amazing things about tunic is the way it
rewards sequence breaking tunic is full
of these like little shortcuts and
alternate ways to get things and
probably the coolest moment is later on
in the game
when you're in one of the final areas
and you take this shortcut that brings
you all the way back to the beginning of
the game that shortcut was there the
entire time and you could have at the
beginning of the game use that shortcut
to skip all the way to that part of the
game if you knew it was there but you
didn't because of the way the game kind
of like naturally hides those elements
it makes you want to immediately replay
the game and be like well wait a minute
if I could have done this in this order
and I could have found this ahead of
time and I've I've never seen a game
uh just so like effortlessly be able to
kind of like capture that that kind of
energy uh and and for me it it's made it
one of the most like impressive and just
like magical experiences I had this year
and it's why it's one of gamespot's uh
top 10 games of 2022.
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it is not often that we get to play
games that tackle topics of
industrialization uprooting Suburbia or
exploring the relationship between
morality and technology or even family
drama that spans Generations yet Norco
manages to tackle all of that while
having hilarious levity and still
deliver a heartwarming story now on the
surface it's this rather
ugly pixelated point-and-click Adventure
but not ugly because of its art but ugly
and how it depicts the world and how the
oil industry has essentially destroyed
this New Orleans Suburbia but in
creating this kind of muddled kind of
gross palette it still manages to
capture this kind of nostalgic warmth
that comes from American Suburbia Norco
is a Southern Gothic fairy tale where
you play as a person who is coming home
after learning about the death of their
mother but Upon returning you also learn
that your brother has gone missing now
this family drama is at the core of the
game but what unravels our very lofty
topics that are seldom seen in other
games it tackles topics of industry in
such a way that is Fantastical and
believable because it is told through
the lens of incredibly heartwarming
believable characters and while a lot of
this sounds incredibly seldom and
serious what's beautiful about Norco is
exactly how funny it is and I urge you
if you play this game listen to the
guy's story about eating a hot dog and I
tell you listen to the whole story
because it is something you'll simply
not regret in the end Norco is a
incredibly serious game that is told
with beautiful pros and is still somehow
without any pretension and an incredibly
funny and all that is uplifted by its
incredible soundtrack that also kind of
Paints the perfect picture just as its
pixel art does too I think it was a
remarkable game that is rarely seen in
the space and it tells a very beautiful
in-depth story but not with big
spectacles and over the top displays of
AAA budgets but it is purely through
just remarkable storytelling and that is
why Norco is well deserving of being in
gamespot's top 10.
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what makes Marvel snap really fantastic
is its Simplicity which is kind of what
you'd expect for a card game that was
designed by a lot of the people behind
Hearthstone but that Simplicity doesn't
come at the cost of depth or any other
considerations like that decks are only
12 cards in this game which doesn't
sound like a lot but what that does is
make the actual deck building process a
really simple and straightforward thing
you can come up with an idea you can get
a new card and be inspired throw a deck
together in just less than a minute and
then try it out and because the matches
themselves are also fairly short they
only last four or five minutes at the
most you can take a deck that you throw
together jump into a few matches try it
out see how it goes and really not feel
like you're wasting your time or
otherwise doing anything terribly taxing
and they can really upend the strategies
that you implement you can go in with
something in mind but what ends up
playing out can be dramatically
different from what you expect and
really because the matches are short it
really isn't painful there's even zones
that will cause your your deck to play
out much differently than you expect
they might replace your deck entirely
with a random set of cards which in a
different context might sound terrible
but that sort of Chaos in the context of
a four minute match is actually a fun
distraction and makes what you're doing
you know a lot of fun and feel different
from time to time
I think what sets Marvel snap apart from
so many other games is just the the low
barrier to entry to trying something new
that experimentation that is just so
much fun whether it's inspired by
getting a new card or just an idea that
you see someone else use and create a
deck and then jump in and try it really
quickly and there's just such a variety
that that stems from that you can always
be trying something new and it's really
satisfying when an idea you have pays
off you know two minutes later with the
short matches the you know easy deck
building there's really ample
opportunity for different strategies and
if nothing else it's a great alternative
to Doom scrolling so if for no other
reason that's why Marvel snap is one of
the best games since 2022.
foreign
[Music]
Sinners plucked from hell to do God's
Dirty Work
but I'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
thank you
neon white is one of our best games of
2022 because of how it forces you to
appreciate speedrunning and basically
just playing Shooters at an insanely
high speed I'm not really into that you
know I'm most I like first person
shooters but I'm not super into the high
speed sort of games but neon white got
me like that just because of just
because of how you're constantly
competing with friends on your friends
list uh you know it's it's almost like a
escalation where I'll beat this mission
in 15 seconds and then someone will beat
it in 14 and then I'll try to do 13 and
then we're splitting seconds by
fractions trying to just beat each other
this is by the tiniest amount and I
found myself jumping back into levels
just over and over and over again I was
checking the scoreboard almost daily to
see if anyone had beaten it and what's
even cooler is that you can actually
compare your times with the developer
times so if you get fast enough that
little icon next your name will change
to red and that'll mean you're faster
than developer and that to me was just
so satisfying uh just speeding through
these levels as quickly as you can it
almost becomes innate it's just I know
exactly what I'm gonna do I don't even
have to think but there is just an
intense level of concentration that
comes to it it's the Flow State I just I
could play for hours and hours and hours
and I felt like I was accomplishing so
much in these like 10 15 20 sometimes 45
second long missions so there's one
mission in neon white kind of early on
that I noticed a bunch of people on my
friends list were doing within eight
seconds and it took me around 20 or so
and I was trying to figure out how that
was possible I ran through the level
like six or seven times couldn't figure
it out turns out I was basically
supposed to bypass the entire set path
in order to basically just jump up to
the finish and when I figured that out
it just kind of
it almost rewrote how my brain was
working when I was playing that game I
was constantly looking for interesting
shortcuts that almost felt like sequence
breaking but were clearly intended
there's such a great moment when you
start to realize that that the way these
levels are built there's completely
alternate ways you can get through them
and that is why neon white is one of
gamespot's favorite games of 2022.
what is your name
Marissa Marcel
when I woke the last time I was into
chaos
I was weak and Confused
I walked down through the villages
I found her in a field
she was still alive
she was beautiful
[Music]
it's hard to talk about immortality
because it is a game of so many
different parts
there are so many different cohesive
things that have to come together to
make the narrative that it has and one
of those things is the performances
which are phenomenal across the board in
different time periods and backstages
and parties and scenes they all come
together to create this world that every
time you click into a new scene
just constantly invigorates your
imagination as to what is happening what
is the context what is who are these
people how do they know each other these
relationships form these different
environments come to life whether it's a
movie set or a party or wherever you are
to create a world that is centered
around this mystery and then on top of
that there's an entire other thing that
I really can't talk about because it's
even better to go in cold and experience
for the first time so there's a moment
in the game where you're entered into a
gallery and these two characters are
talking and just having a conversation
you're getting little context for what's
happening but the game
forces you to click on the painting in
the gallery which takes you to another
time and space and cast of characters
and completely different feel
even the filming of it like the actual
look of the scene itself is completely
different and that's when I realized and
got hooked on the rabbit hole that you
go down with each new scene and each new
character in each new plot development
in this massive mystery that I I just
wanted to keep clicking and I wanted to
keep finding every possible scene that
these characters inhabit because they
are so well acted they are so well set
up they are so well
I don't know the the mood in each of
them is so palpable that
you can
jump from time to time
and and feel like you're in a completely
different
Dimension which is I guess what they're
trying to get at
um
and so that is why immortality is one of
the best games of 2022.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
rabbits Sparks of Hope is one of the
best games of 2022 simply because it's
Charming it's resourceful and it gives
you the complete package of what you
really want from a tactics game of a
strategy game like in its package and it
does so in a way that not many games in
this genre really do prioritizing
movement in a way that most games in
this genre don't really do in most
strategy games going from point A to
point B that's it that's all you do
there's like no real strategy to it
other than getting closer to what you're
trying to hit but in Mario plus rabbits
going from point A to point B gives you
a chance to jump to dive through people
to completely change your strategy and
unlock new movements and abilities and
the addition of real time elements for
you to dodge for your enemies to dodge
adds this whole different blend of
combat to the Encounters in this game
that not many games like it are able to
accomplish and it creates something that
even when you're looking at it is
charming and really pretty and like
rabid Mario's one of the funniest
characters like of this year at the same
time is a challenge is like asking you
to really think through where you want
to move before you attack and not a lot
of games like in this genre really task
you with doing that and that's really
special that's really cool and it
creates this form of tactics that
honestly you just haven't really seen in
the slew of tactics games that we've
gotten this year and for that reason I
think Mario plus rabbit Sparks of Hope
is one of the best games of 2022.
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm actually annoyed that you have taken
me away from this game to talk about
this game and that's because vampire
survivors is brilliant because it is not
a game that you have to really kind of
gear yourself up to play because it is
so simple to play it you can play with
one hand if you wanted to all you are
doing is controlling your character as
you walk around the map and your
character will Auto attack and all of
these monsters basically everything hell
can throw at you come and attack you
your character will fight them and the
enemies will drop gems you pick up the
gems you level up you unlock new things
you unlock new pieces of equipment new
Buffs and then on the surface could be
it right that could be an enjoyable game
all of its own however once you realize
that you can level up those weapons and
you level up those Buffs and then you
can combine them together to create
super super powerful weapons and then
you can do things like unlock the
grimoire or the map on different levels
and do different kind of mini quests
Within These worlds it becomes half a
hypnotic experience where all you're
doing is just kind of watching the bar
go up and just yeah I'm leveling up I'm
getting stronger I'm killing all these
enemies and then part this exercise in
logic in I know I'm in the library I
know this enemy is going to come get me
at some point what is the best gear that
I could have at this point what is the
best combo of stuff that is gonna make
sure that I get to the end of the level
and it gets to the point where there's
so much going on on screen that you
can't look away and I mean that in kind
of the best way that's why I say
hypnotic because there are the sounds of
you picking up the gems there's the
sound of you attacking there's a sound
of you leveling up and so all of this
together means that you are kind of just
pulled in and for 30 minutes because
that's the other great thing about
vampire survivors is that realistically
all you have to do is survive for 30
minutes and so it is this like lack of
investment on your part you know I play
it on my steam deck all the time when
I'm watching TV I don't want to tell you
how many hours I put into this I don't
want to tell you how many hours my
friends have put into vampire survivors
it is wonderful in a year where there
have been so many like big emotional
stories huge open worlds vampire
survivors is a game where Success is Not
only completely achievable and
attainable the stakes are low but it is
constantly rewarding you just for being
there and that is why vampire survivors
is one of the best games of 2022.
[Music]
oh my God
of War Ragnarok simply put is one of the
best and most complex story driven games
in the AAA space of the past few years
when we think about AAA we tend to think
of like big epic Grand cinematic moments
and God of War Ragnarok most definitely
does that I mean it's quite literally
Ragnarok it's the end of the world I
mean it's right there in the name but
beyond that what Ragnarok does is it
takes this huge epic Grand scale and
makes it felt on an individual and
character level in such rich and complex
ways every character from atreus to
Kratos to Odin to Thor to freaking
through like who thought thrued would be
such a like deep emotional character in
a game like this gets such Rich
relationships and ideas and story lines
to explore that it's honestly just
completely uh resonant in every single
second of this game beyond that though
the performances and this most
definitely driven by Christopher Judge
my man teal from Stargate sg1 uh are so
excellent and nuanced and it just really
brings forward what you can do with
performance in video games and I just am
in awe at every second of just seeing
these actors get to play these
characters and one final thing on the
story of this game is that while it may
on the surface be about like mythology
and like these big gods and things like
that it's a story that is very much
about today talking about systems of
Oppression and how we
um as individuals fit Within These uh
these systems and how we can push back
to fight for a more diverse and
fulfilling world and how we sort of
create coalitions to push back against
people who want to dominate others and I
found this game so deeply prescient
despite the fact that it's set you know
millions of years ago in some
mythological world it was just
absolutely wonderful and then finally it
should go without saying the game has
some of the best like combat and
gameplay mechanics of any game uh this
year uh I I Adore just like going up
against the bosses and the sort of uh
enemies in this game and and like
figuring out their varieties and their
move sets and how best I can sort of
fight back against them I would spend
hours just fighting one boss trying to
get all of the uh exact timings down and
it was just so much fun and while I did
want to throw my controller several
times I always did so out of love so
with that all being said that is why God
of War Ragnarok is one of the best games
this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I think that pentiment is a bit
unassuming at first I think that it
seems like a very Niche game designed
for a very Niche group of Gamers it
wasn't something that like drew me in
immediately I didn't think that I you
know it was a must play for me but the
second that I started playing I was
completely enamored by it I found that
there were so many themes and so many
feelings it explored that are so
Universal and it seems like you wouldn't
think that there'd be all these
Universal themes or these points of
Connections in a game that is about 16th
century monks and you know that has this
art style that's illuminated manuscripts
like you wouldn't expect a game to
tackle political issues and emotional
issues like things that are deeply
intimate and deeply personal with as
much tact as it does
um and it does so in a way where you
don't just feel like you're looking at
history as something that happened in
the past or you're looking at these
people as something that you can't
connect to you find pieces of yourself
and pieces of the places you know and
the people you know in this history
which is kind of the point of the game
overall it does a really good job of
having that sort of meta narrative at
the front the whole time you're playing
you're thinking of how history really
isn't as far back and as removed from us
as you think it is it's actually
something that we're living right now
and the fact that this this game could
come out and and make such a bold
statement and kind of have that presence
to it is really incredible especially
for something that you know I was
shocked by how well it also explores
depression that's not something that you
would think that you would get from this
game it's not something it's not a game
that markets itself as being you know
something that is about mental health
but so much of the second and third act
explore that feeling and not being sure
of you know the choices that you make in
life and you know where it's all leading
you and so often with these games or
their choice space like pentimen is
um you feel like there is a right choice
and a wrong choice but when you you know
live life you realize that it's not as
simple as that and there are no right or
wrong choices there are just Shades of
Gray and pentiment really explores that
um and kind of the heaviness and the
burden with having that responsibility
it does the choice system honestly in
the best way that I've ever seen
implemented in any game and it's just
such a beautiful cohesive experience
that I really think it's a it's a must
play and that is why it is one of the
best games of 2022.
it is now my great honor to reveal games
spots game of the year it is
Alden ring in the words of Tomorrow
Hussain the fact that from software has
been able to instill the sense of
Freedom alone is impressive but being
able to do this while also strengthening
the design principles that are core to
its game is a Monumental achievement it
ensures that all these years later the
defining features of the Studio's games
remain fresh Elden ring is a game that
delivers a role-playing experience
stronger than any that from software has
created before one that encourages
experimentation and venturing outside
your comfort zone and rewards it with
memorable gameplay opportunities
and there you have it that is game
spot's top 10 best of the year now I
just need to reiterate that there are a
lot of fantastic games that came out
this year and all of us hear all the
lovely beautiful folk behind me we spent
a lot of time trying to figure out the
the 10 that represented us as Game Spot
but that doesn't mean that the game you
love isn't good too so most importantly
just just enjoy what you enjoy love what
you love and play games because really
at the end of the day that's just what
we all like doing okay I'm Kurt this is
Gamespot until next time till next year
see you later